on va retrouver sur l'échiquier
politique
maintenant le président des républicains
bonsoir aller président jusque jusque
quand jusque dans quelques semaines oui
dans quelques dans quelques jours mais
vous avez encore des choses à dire et
des responsabilités puisque ce soir
d'abord un premier regard sur votre
score celui des républicains on
s'attendait à quelque chose de dur très
dur c'est moins dur que prévu oui c'est
lié d'abord à l'ancrage territorial de
nous de nos candidats ça fait là ça fait
la différence dans beaucoup de beaucoup
de circonscriptions et on voit bien que
on est en situation de jouer un rôle
déterminant dans cette législature entre
la voie des extrêmes et l'immobilisme
conduit par là la majorité du président
macron si tant est qu'il est toujours
une majorité est-ce que vous renvoyer
dos à dos vous la nuque et de
rassemblement national comme le fait il
ya quelques minutes la première ministre
ce sont des extrêmes de chaque côté
extrême gauche extrême droite c'est le
matraquage assuré pour toutes les
classes moyennes puisque c'est une
gabegie de dépenses c'est ce alors leur
programme c'est des dépenses des
dépenses des dépenses pas de recette est
donc un matraquage assuré pour toutes
les classes moyennes vous voilà un parti
charnière vous allez probablement lettre
au sein de l'assemblée nationale dans
quelque temps entre les deux tours vous
l'êtes également dans beaucoup de
circonscriptions 19% ce soir ça veut
dire que ça pèse lourd ça veut dire que
vous allez faire des choix que vous
allez discuter négocier des choses avec
ensemble ou pas du tout ça veut dire que
nous voterons nous seront constructifs
nous voterons les textes qui vont dans
le bon sens nous opposerons durement
lorsque ça ne sera pas le cas et surtout
ce que j'espère est ce que je demande
aux français aujourd'hui c'est de nous
faire confiance parce que nous nous
pourrons faire bouger les choses nous ne
sommes pas pour la révolution permanente
nous ne sommes pas pour le matraquage
des classes moyennes au contraire pour
que ce pays se réforme et les députés
les républicains demain seront en
situation de faire bouger les choses et
de faire en sorte que des réformes
nécessaires à notre pays arrive vous
avez 13 7% pour le moment ça a évolué on
voit on verra combien de députés et
combien sont dans les projections pour
bien comprendre entre les deux tours
quand il ya un candidat de la nuque face
à un candidat d'ensemble quel est votre
choix c'est au cas par cas ça se négocie
comme ça on le définira demain puisque
on a un conseil stratégique
il pourrait y avoir une décision
nationale mais il ya une ligne qui a
toujours été clair c'est aucune voix
pour les extrêmes dire ce soit l'extrême
droite ou l'extrême gauche encore une
fois c'est les classes moyennes qui vont
payer parce qu'il faudra bien aller
chercher des recettes quelque part et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui nos entreprises
sont étouffés de charge de normes toutes
les classes moyennes paient en
permanence ne peuvent plus et nous
pouvons faire bouger est-ce que ce que
j'entends là d'un côté on à la nuque
cette coalition de la gauche aux mains
de l'autre côté le rassemblement
national est ce que dans ce grand centre
centre droit centre gauche les
républicains n'ont pas toutes leurs
places pour cette nouvelle législature
est ce que un contrat gouvernemental
serait possible ce n'est pas dans un
contrat gouvernemental nous sommes dans
l'opposition à la république en marche
mais nous pouvons par nos propositions
d'amendements nous avons la majorité au
sénat et nous pourront influer à
l'assemblée et faire en sorte que ce
pays se redresse le bilan des manuels
macron pourquoi il est aussi mauvais
pourquoi il ya une telle sanction
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'aucune
réforme n'ont été apportée que ce soit
effectivement sur les retraites que ce
soit sur l'emploi sur la sécurité sur le
contrôle de l'immigration tout ça était
laissée à vau l'eau et à chaque fois
nous avons toujours été force de
proposition contrairement aux députés du
front national qui ont toujours brillé
par leur absence ou à ceux de la
république à ceux de la france insoumise
qui a toujours prôné l'obstruction total
donc nous nous avons une voix qui
aujourd'hui est celle de la réforme et
celle des classes moyennes il est là
pour soutenir et sauver les classes et
serge un cominois juste trente secondes
si j'ai bien compris effectivement on
attendra effectivement les décisions si
c'est une décision nationale pour
soutenir effectivement les candidats
d'ensemble ou pas de leur côté vous
réclamez qu'effectivement quand les
républicains sont présents que ensemble
appelle à soutenir les candidats
républicains personne ne peut se
satisfaire d'une assemblée où il y
aurait une majorité avec les deux
extrêmes que ce soit les cinq droite ou
l'extrême gauche vous voyez bien que
dans le programme économique c'est blanc
bonnet et bonnet blanc c'est la même
chose